I just want to know more about it this
love music
[Music]
so we're joined by Maya from studio mdh
our great to have you with this thank
you so much for coming in and I'm super
excited by this game probably more than
most other games just because it's just
so fresh it feels so which is weird
because it's quite old style but it
feels so fresh and different so what's
happened since what's happened to d3
yeah well thanks for having us here
we're very excited be at Gamescom this
year with a brand new demo so we're
wrapping up development right now and as
you are probably aware a cup add is a
run-and-gun platformer where you can run
duck jump shoot Perry and we also have
other levels where you can play as a
shmup okay Julia's gonna talk to you in
a second about the animation stuff I'm
really keen to know more about how the
gameplay works and what the kind of
gameplay influences are on cuphead race
we were heavily inspired by a games of
the late 80s early 90s in retro retro
games so gunstar heroes contra Megaman
and games are an archetype we were
talking about earlier yeah so there are
some levels where you do a play as a
schmuck just like also mode theory
that's like using the force I always
think that Zen Norman you can actually
process it it's just really really quick
but it's just it's you and that you're
on that zone and so we have to talk
about the actual style of it as well
because I mean talk about the process in
creating the look of cockpit because
it's pretty unique yeah so every single
game every single frame in the game is
hand drawn with pencil and paper and it
and inked as well on papers so also all
the backgrounds are watercolor paintings
and there's nearly three hours of custom
jazz music custom jazz yes like my other
everything in this game which is unusual
for a video game has been hand crafted
yeah there's like real artisanship going
into this right yeah we really wanted to
maintain be authentic to the era of
1930s I mean cuz obviously like older
cartoons were a bit weird a little bit
strange and obviously you know seeing
cuphead there's you know there's it's
very
like that was that kind of always the
the idea from the start to kind of keep
that most definitely most definitely it
was a dry for us especially to it was
that surrealistic
approach to animating where there were
no boundaries yeah so we really loved
the idea where Felix the Cat could you
know rip off his tail and use as a match
like something on fire so that was the
draw to basically making very wacky
crazy bosses and enemies that sort of
sounds like when you say it like that
that sounds a little bit horrific in
some sort of way doesn't it but it makes
sense of that era that was super weird
very resourceful as well I mean we're
seeing gameplay on screen here now you
can totally see that that old-school
shoot-'em-up gameplay now I grew up on
those games and I remember them being
tough and punishing their kind of
difficulty level yeah so it was designed
to be challenging but we also have some
modern nods let's make it fair so your
progression of stayed so every time that
you sit down to play the game you're not
starting all over again yeah you have
infinite lives and when playing in co-op
you also have the ability to revive your
partner if they die ox great if you
catch them while they're floating
off-screen yeah we've also designed the
game with multiple modes so there is
easy and normal mode and and then once
you complete the game in normal mode we
unlock new game+ for meats which always
sounds really friendly but I think you
can actually switch between the
different kind of difficulties for each
level yes so you can play a normal mode
for one level and if you're if you don't
have much experience on the next one you
can switch it back down to simple just
you get completely beaten you're like
I'm not quite a new game I can't wait to
play in coach co-op that's gonna be
great right yes yes no definitely it's
it's a little more chaotic on screen
it's the bullet hell but like I said
you're your partner can pop in and pop
out at any time by pressing any key
throughout the level the boss health it
does scale up a little bit when you're
hot mode but it also scales back down if
you've lost your partner great ok I love
the fact that one of our biggest tears
that are he through press briefing
for the release date of cuphead so why
don't you remind everyone what that day
is yes
so Quebec comes out on September 29th on
Xbox one Windows 10 in steam excellent
and people here at Gamescom this week
are going to be able to play on the Xbox
booth as well so that's fantastic
Maya thank you so much for thank you